hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in nikka McKeon
ethics book 7 Aristotle discusses in
addition to vice and unrestrained or
lack of self-control that is across yep
he also discusses another state of a
person's character or personality then
in greek is called theory altace and
this can be translated as brutality or
as bestiality LOL bestiality has some
unfortunate other connotations that
might distract a person but it's coming
from the word on theatre which means
animal or beast so brutality or
bestiality it's saying that the person
has become like one of the nonhuman
lowering animals Arizona was also going
to talk about morbid dispositions more
or less anonymously it does make some
important distinctions between Morgan
dispositions and straight out brutality
but then they kind of get you know
brought back together and I think in
some respects he's not so concerned with
whether
something is directly this or directly
that he's interested in the category as
as such and like it we're this is
something distinct from a moral vice and
we'll see why in just a moment and it's
also distinct from a lack of self
control where it fundamentally differs
from both of those is that is aerosol
says that the highest part of the human
being which we don't always listen to
this that's the case in lack of
restraint or lack of self-control we
know what the good is and we don't do it
right and some of us may be a cratic
generally you know we typically don't do
it we know we're supposed to do but
we're not yet vicious right so we're
bothered by that some of us may be a
cratic in certain circumstances under
certain temptations and then you know on
the other side there's being soft
controlled and being virtuous being
vicious is a matter of something that is
within a person's control doesn't mean
that they can control themself at every
moment but it doesn't mean that that
person is doing things voluntarily they
have managed to damage within themselves
you might say their moral compass their
their higher part their faculty that
tells them what is actually indeed right
or wrong good or bad curd for human
beings in and with themselves but they
still do have some sort of moral
principle that they're operating
according to it's just a bad one right
and this is developed through through
habit aristotle says Andrew how we
choose to do things the person who is
actually brutal or suffering from a
morbid disposition that part of the
human being has been put out of
commission it's not there like I think
he says you know there there could be a
loss of it or some sort of damage that
has taken place could be partial damage
could be entire damage could be lacking
you could have never been there in the
first place and this is aerosolizing of
the
national intellectual part of the human
being something that is Racine in many
other discussions in you know for
example they can McCain ethics book six
in book seven and also in book two is
really going to be necessary for us to
be good morally in the sense of being
virtuous or even in the sense of being
self control so this part has been has
been racked you might say or put out of
commission Aristotle will actually say
that this is not as morally bad as vice
so he's sounds like he's in certain
sense giving these people to pass and
he's not holding them morally
responsible for the sorts of things that
they do as he would indeed a vicious
person who you may say well they they
can't really control there's all sorts
of nice arguments about that late in the
book three about you know what degree
advices is something that is actually
voluntary when it comes to the brutal
person or the person suffering from a
mortgage disposition though Aristotle
says that they're actually more horrible
in the sense that we would feel horror
at their condition or we might feel
horror about what they might in fact do
or already have done the calls them
football Tyrone which means more
fear-inspiring more fearful these are so
there is a kind of madness there but
it's not the same thing as the moral
badness involved advice it's still not
goodness he's still not saying that
these people are you know just be
treated in the same as everybody else as
a matter of fact would be extremely
imprudent to do so but he is
dissociating this from the normal sphere
of moral concerns before we go into how
this happens let's look at some of the
examples that he actually gives here he
says that some of these would be the
creature in women's forum that's set to
rip up pregnant
females and devour their offspring so
what we're talking about their these
canna fictional scary storybook
characters Aristotle considers that to
be lower in a certain respect than the
advice what else certain savage tribes
on the coasts of the Black Sea that was
sort of barbarians perfect slots for
them who are alleged to delight in raw
meat or in human flesh cannibals others
a lot of them which each in turn
provides a child for the common banquet
or the reported depravity of phalaris
there's there's a great person who is
you know pretty horrible he creates a a
bull in which you put people and then
you heat up the the brazen bull and
their screams of agony is that are
roasted alive are turned by means of
some musical instruments into sort of a
piping sound that the bull makes that's
pretty horrible that that is pretty
fear-inspiring and when you ask why
people like that do what they do you
know you could attribute a device but
you might say look they're like beyond
the pale they are just horrible horrible
people and there's something
fundamentally wrong with them if you
were to sit down with them it might be
able to engage in some intellectual
discussion or some argument that they
probably won't be able to really grasp
what what is actually wrong with them as
such somebody like Aristotle would say
about this what are some other examples
he talks about the madman that will
offer up his mother to the gods and
partook of the sacrifice and he ate some
of the sacrifice plucking out the hair
people who you know pull their hair out
biting the nails eating cinders and
earth something that we're familiar with
because it happens sometimes in the
American South due to as a theorized
some sort of mineral deficiency perhaps
combined with some psychological
mechanisms and then he mentions sexual
perversion which which could
a whole bunch of different things he
also talks a little bit later on about
several other examples and you know how
to here we go people who are
unrestrained but but vicious with
respect to certain behaviors if it goes
super super far then they can become
brutal in this in the sense he talks
about the person who is framed in
everything the phobic person not just a
phobic of one thing but but everything
we might think of summin some mental
disorders as falling into this case as
well people who are incredibly phobic of
a range of things that keep them from
being able to have a normal life or even
relatively normal life people who are
who are foolish by nature you know
irrational by nature living certain
solely by sensation like certain remote
tribes of barbarians as he says people
who lose their reason due to some sort
of disease he talks about epileptics for
example something we still don't fully
understand but they certainly understood
much less back in his time so this is a
very large class of possible types of
behavior and when he says it involves
having desires and pleasures for things
that are not naturally pleasant in arms
you can also add to this they aren't
within the range of the things that most
people are working with you know
somebody is greedy for example less
that's a vice right and we can
understand that because we could say
well wealth is attractive because you
can do stuff with it but you know when
you're pulling out of your hair and you
ask the person why are you pulling out
your hair to get some incoherent the
answer it's probably a matter of this
and Aristotle says it's about pleasure
but it could also be to avoid pain or it
could be 22
you know do other things as well perhaps
a motivation by fear or anxiety if we go
on and we look at how this actually
happens he doesn't give us any sort of
you know deep explanation in terms of
the mechanics of the human psyche but it
does tell us about what could be going
now so one thing you talk about is a
lack of development or another way to
translating this is mutilation neurosis
it's also a word that is used in some
context for blindness so there could be
something going on where person is just
damaged in that way I can also be
developed by certain habits doing these
things over and over again so where the
habit itself becomes an absolute
compulsion or addiction and you know
essentially instead of being a habit
that the person has the person is
something that the habit has natural
depravity he talks about it as well but
doesn't go go that far into it this
would be perhaps some sort of birth
defect something wrong that way but he
also does talk about disease know some
physical ailment that produces
particular effects perhaps you know if a
person became totally lethargic because
they're actually suffering from some
sort of virus that saps all of their
energy this is that that could fit into
this right insanity he talks about Manya
a a new strata of the mind insanity than
mine habitual abuse he also talks about
in the word that's used there who breeds
o meno is he staying with those who have
been abused he talks about them in some
cases having been abused since childhood
we could think about the role of certain
types of childhood abuse for some of the
people that experience that as placing
them in this kind of state we want to be
extremely careful about just saying well
anybody who suffered abuse is
automatically in this state because
they're not there are many people who
you know have horrible abuse and go on
to become virtuous people it's difficult
this could be something that they have
to overcome I could cause a lot of
impediments that somebody who had a much
happier upbringing oh yeah you know
helpers along the way doesn't have to
incur but the fact that some people come
out at horrific situations and aren't
automatically you know in this sort of
condition should give us a bit of pause
in globally attributing it to anybody
who has something like that going on
excessive vices we talked about that
Aristotle gives you some examples of
this he says that those who are
experiencing folly cowardice lack of
self restraint or self indulgence with
respect to certain appetites ill temper
you know anger in some ways whenever
they run to excess and remember we're
not just talking about ready to learn
excess we're talking about super excess
these become either beastial or morbid
conditions so you know Aris level
doesn't think that you know you can just
if you're vicious you just you're at
least you're not gonna be beast you you
can actually go off the deep end from
being so vicious in those respects that
you become beasts you use the example of
the coward who is afraid of everything
uses the example of the person who just
is lacking any sort of intelligence at
all he's also talking about people who
indulge in sexual behavior and pleasures
to such a degree that they lose sight of
everything else that could also include
you know the pleasures of eating and
drinking or intoxicants and we do think
about anger anger can go so far that a
person can become literally so rageful
that they cannot control it anymore and
so you know this is this is an
interesting topic you know in part
because it
shows us that there's a lot more depth
and dimension to Aristotle's ethics than
just simply thinking about vice and
virtue this is you might say moving in a
different plane than vice or virtue but
it is a very important moral category
for us to think about nonetheless